die kathedrale notre dame steht ins land
bild
[Musik]
die berühmteste frau der welt ist tot
gründungsjubiläum sahen damals 277
millionen menschen wenn 96 jahren ist
die queen uhr verstorben die welt
trauert um sie und damit herzlich
willkommen zum film nach spezial meine
gäste heute abend sind
fdp-außenpolitiker alexander graf
lambsdorff star kulissen publizist hans
ulrich jörges die stellvertretende bild
chefredakteur in tanja may und
weltpolitik reporter viktor wachse in
cambridge studiert hat graf lambsdorff
elisabeth die zweite war eine sehr
außergewöhnliche frau was wird von ihr
am meisten in erinnerung bleiben ich
glaube dass sie es geschafft hat eine
zeit der beständigkeit herzustellen in
einer zeit radikalen wandels
großbritannien hat sich ja total
geändert in ihrer lebenszeit vom empire
zu einem ganz normalen start von einer
modischen also rein weißen nation zu
einer total bunten nation man muss sich
ja nur mal die neue regierung angucken
die vier wichtigsten minister sind alle
nicht weiß und sie hat in dieser zeit
einen anker geboten ein anker der
verlässlichkeit ein anker der
beständigkeit deswegen ist es ja auch so
dass wir alle wir alle hier heute und
die ganze welt über die queen redet sie
ist ja nicht die einzige königin die es
auf der welt gibt aber sie ist sie war
unsere queen genauso wie die queen der
engländerin und einwender kenne ja warum
ist die queen was graf lambsdorff gerade
angesprochen eine so besonders weil hat
natürlich recht es gibt ja nicht nur die
eine königin
ich denke die königin oder die queen hat
es geschafft vom tag eins an ihrer
regentschaft sagt ja ihr leben komplett
der krone untergeordnet und das hat man
ja jetzt auch gesehen bis zum letzten
atemzug wirklich hat sie ihren dienst
getan sie war sie hat noch vor zwei
tagen ja die britische die neue
britische premierministerin eingeführt
im urlaub in schottland hatte sie
empfangen und jetzt ist sie tot und sie
hat wirklich bis zur letzten minute
gezeigt ja was es bedeutet königin zu
sein hat dem alles untergeordnet selbst
ihre große liebe prinz philip ihre
kinder ihre familie eben alles viktor
weiß wird nur besser heute auch schon
den ganzen tag im chat verläuft und mit
deinen wünschen denn dein kommilitonen
aus england und einen freund fort wie
sehr trauert england um ihre königin ich
glaube trauen ist vielleicht gar nicht
mehr das richtige wort sondern da ist
was zerbrochen was die wo das wort
trauer gar nicht dem gerecht wird
brauchen was man nie wieder bringen kann
etwas undenkbares und das witzig was ich
heute festgestellt habe durch meine
englischen freundeskreise war wie sehr
gerade die junge generation die leute
unter 30 völlig fertig waren noch nicht
wussten wo sie hin sollen denn die haben
ihr ganzes leben unter der queen gehabt
und irgendwie england ist durch seine
wilde zeit gegangen drechsel corona war
da die hatten sonderwegs war alles
anfahren sind jetzt ist das land der
riesen inflation riesen krisen und die
queen war immer da sie was stabil und
jetzt ist sie weg und kann es
nachvollziehen ich habe auch getraut
muss ich sagen ich habe eine besondere
beziehung zu großbritannien ich habe
lange für reuters gearbeitet habe viele
englische freunde mein bester ist immer
noch in london da war früher mal
chefredakteur von reuters dem hab ich
gleich kontrolliert und ich habe mir
dann einen whisky ein geschenk den habe
ich auf sie gehoben zu hause
ich kann das gut verstehen für mich war
die frau kulturell immer eine figur aus
den sechziger jahren immer 60 er jahre
die kleidung was sie was sie getan hat
was sie gesagt hat wie sie sich bewegt
hat die tradition die sie ausgestrahlt
hat die war für mich keine 70er 80er
90er jahre figur schon gar keine nach
der jahrtausendwende und ich glaube dass
sie das was sie zusammengehalten hat
jetzt auch zerfallen dort in den
nächsten jahren das ist für
großbritannien sehr schmerzlich ich
glaube zunächst mal dass der kommerz
zerfällt also die der britische könig
oder die königin sind ja staatsoberhaupt
eine ganze reihe von ländern australien
kanada noch eine ganze reihe anderer
länder in kanada in australien hat schon
eine diskussion gegeben dass das zu ende
sein muss wenn die queen mal nicht mehr
da ist und jetzt unter prinz nämlich
brennt sondern king charles wird das zu
ende gehen vielleicht eine frage von ein
zwei jahren und dann bin ich mal
gespannt im oktober 223 soll es wieder
eine volksbefragung in schottland geben
über die unabhängigkeit obwohl king
charles in seiner jugend in schottland
auf einem internat war und immer eine
beziehung zu dem land hatte und gerne im
schottenrock rumlaufen ist glaube ich
nicht dass er das zusammenhält könnte
mir vorstellen dass die
unabhängigkeitsbewegung dort befördert
wird durch den wechsel und wir sehen ja
im übrigen wenn wir das verallgemeinern
auf uns beziehen unsere lebenswelt wie
sehen wir die welt der tod dieser frau
ist ein symbol für den zerfall der
lebens und machtverhältnisse wie wir sie
kennen wir sehen das in der ukraine im
verhältnis zu russland wir werden wieder
einen eisernen vorhang kriegen und
wahrscheinlich über jahrzehnte hinweg
sehr schwierige verhältnisse hier und
was diese frau in großbritannien
überstrahlt hat und was hier bei uns
immer weniger zu überstrahlen ist weil
solche figuren gibt es bei uns nicht
mehr das für mich das hauptthema dieser
zeiten im staatsversagen in
großbritannien ist das gesundheitswesen
so schlecht organisiert dass ich leute
die zähne selbst 10 uhr als sie
miteinander zu bezahlen können diese
armut bewegung alles das wird jetzt
sichtbar werden ich würde einmal nach
gerne auf die von dir angesprochene
zeitenwende eingehen und da graf
lambsdorff fragen ob er bei der these
mit gibt dass es jetzt einen schnitt
gibt und diese konstante nicht mehr zu
halten ist auch meine mitarbeiterin
meine engste mitarbeiterin seit vielen
jahren bei mir die sagte heute mein gott
das ist jetzt wirklich eine zeitenwende
und für viele menschen und ich glaube
gerade menschen in unserer generation
new york ist und ich
endet heute so in gewisser weise das
zwanzigste jahrhundert für elisabeth war
der erste premierminister den sie hatte
winston churchill ja das war der der
hitler besiegt hat das muss man sich mal
vorstellen man kann sich das gar nicht
klar machen was das bedeute aber das ist
ja auch so ein ergebnis noch aus der
zeit des empire aus dem neunzehnten
jahrhundert ob es zerbrechen wird oder
nicht ich bin nicht ganz so
pessimistisch was das ganze commonwealth
angeht weil charles einen guten ruf hat
inzwischen kanada aber hanna dann
australien wird wie kanada australien
mögen eine ausnahme sagen viele länder
an die dem kommando angehören die da
noch interessant sind aber dieser diese
dieser dieses gefühl der zeitenwende
dass das das zwanzigste jahrhundert mit
dem abschied von elisabeth jetzt auch zu
verabschieden ist endgültig ein für alle
mal wenn wir uns zusammen gehalten was
war da die rolle dass man sagt und das
gibt es jetzt nicht mehr sie hatte der
hunde sie hat im grunde die monarchie
stabilisiert in einem unmoralischen
zeitalter 2 ein zeitalter der republik
das war eine zeitalter der der
unabhängigkeit aus britischer sich der
dekolonisierung vergessen wenn die
ganzen ländern afrika in asien indien
bangladesch
ghana kenia als all diese länder über
die wir so reden das sind alles länder
die entstanden sind im wegbrechen von
großbritannien war das ein bisschen
kompliziert aber das wird jetzt so weit
und deswegen ist es sozusagen eine
wirkliche ja eine wirkliche zeitenwende
ein ende dieses jahrhunderts mit dem
ableben dieser und die monarchie in
großbritannien war ja mehrfach gefährdet
ernsthaft die jetzige premier ministerin
war mal diesmal gegen die monarchie
angetreten die waren anderen partei bei
den liberaldemokraten und war hat eine
kampagne gemacht für die abschaffung der
monarchie und die man lieber ernsthaft
gefährdet nach dianas tod weil diese
frau die jetzt gestorben ist so
hartherzig war das darf man nicht über
vergessen zu hartherzigkeit dass sie
kein zeichen ihres mitgefühls gegeben
hat werden die briten
gab damals als der jänner gestorben ist
hieß es sie sei hart herzlich weil sie
nicht sofort raus gegangen ist das ein
palast und nicht sofort gezeigt wie sie
trauert aber ich glaube da sie ein sehr
großes herz hatte und das sieht man auch
jetzt wie sie es geschafft hat diese
familie zusammenzuhalten auch jetzt
william und harry die beiden jungen
prinzen wie die sich zerstritten haben
und trotzdem sie hat es immer auch prinz
andrew die skandale die star gibt also
sie hat es geschafft diese familie
zusammenzuhalten und bei der jänner war
sie zunächst glaubt gar nicht mal das es
hartherzig von ihr war sondern sie hat
ja von anfang an gesagt emotionen haben
der öffentlichkeit nichts verloren was
ich denke was ich fühle bleibt in den
palast marussia und aliena verurteilt
weil die ist gestorben nachdem sie mit
body im hotel ritz in paris war das
gehört sich nicht
bevor sie gestorben ist das jahre nicht
dass mit der wollte sie kein umgang mehr
haben keine figur mit dem königshaus
nun haben sollen wie jetzt sagt sie ist
herzlich bedeutet das doch im
umkehrschluss charles ist weich herzig
denn er hat ja seine liebe der charlie
hat einen sehr schwierigen lebensweg
hinter sich der ist von seinem vater
verachtet worden weil er kein harter
junge war das hat der vater immer
gezeigt und die mutter hat es auch nicht
ausgeglichen der der charles hat sich
selbst gefunden der ist ja jetzt ein
grün angehauchte mensch da kann man
wirklich gespannt sein wie sie regiert
der wahl geht er wie verhält er sich ich
bin gespannt auf ihn und findet es gut
dass herr könig wird wenn ich mir die
figuren angucke die sonst in frage
kommen finde ich das gut da ist jetzt
auch einmal noch mal die ganz spannende
frage liebe und ich würde sagen das hat
nämlich das ist doch ein sehr enges
verhältnis gab zwischen charles und der
königin und ich mag sie es abgesehen vom
thron jubiläum
er steht von hunderttausenden von
menschen und er sagt mami und also ich
glaube die beiden ja aber die beiden ja
heute ist wie immer gesucht und sie hat
ja nicht kommen und das ist nicht etwas
für ihren fall of man nicht vergessen
sie hätte ihn nieder die genannt ihren
vater also da ist ja schon angekündigt
hat ein sehr enges verhältnis mit dem
vater ja aber immer privat im team genau
aber ich glaube nicht dass es kein
kaltherzig war und man sieht es sehr sie
hat einfach gesagt gefühl haben nach
draußen nichts verloren wir regeln das
innerhalb der familie innerhalb der
palastmauern und man sieht ja auch
anmelden und harry die beiden die ja
wirklich an der ganzen königsfamilie
kein gutes haar lassen aber die königin
und prinz philip die beiden stehen über
allem und auch man sieht auch ich habe
vorhin gerade fotos gesehen harry wir
jetzt auf dem weg ist nach nach
schottland ins schloss es fix und fertig
er sieht wirklich da kam zu spät er kam
zu spät aber man sieht es hat ihn ins
mark getroffen dass eine großmutter
gestorben ist und daran sieht man sie
hat ein sehr enges verhältnis zu den
enkelkindern und ich glaube auch dass
sie mit den kindern ein enges verhältnis
hatte estlands doch was darum sie denn
wir haben jetzt schon davon gesprochen
wird ja der nächste könig werden so
haben sich ja es ist wahr menschen
gefragt ob es auch william werden könnte
die tradition ich bin dafür ich bin
dagegen
denn diese rolle ausfüllen er hatte mal
gesagt also hat mal gesagt er würde
lieber politische änderung machen als
nur orden zu erteilen die rolle aus
charles ist ein sehr politischer mensch
oder jörges hat ja eben schon mal an
bedeutet ich habe ihn mal erlebt zur 75
zum 75 jahrestag der befreiung von
auschwitz durfte ich unseren
bundespräsidenten begleiten nach yad
vashem das ist die zentrale gedenkstätte
in israel prinz charles hat die rede
gehalten das war eine sehr politische
rede ein rede eben für toleranz gegen
rassismus gegen antisemitismus auch
würdigung der britischen soldaten oder
damals 20 soldaten die das gemacht haben
als war sehr politisch und ich glaube
dass er als jemand der jetzt mit 70 ist
und schon seit langem die geschäfte im
buckingham palace führt das weiß man
nach außen nicht so sehr aber seit zehn
fünfzehn jahren werden die geschäfte im
buckingham palace im grunde von charles
geführt er hat die erfahrung er hat den
punkt das politische interesse und er
hat auch das bewusstsein für die
bedeutung der krone weil die krone ist
größer als jede person die sie trägt das
bringt charles mit und insofern glaube
ich auch wenn er sicher natürlich nicht
eine rolle ausfüllen kann die der seiner
mutter vergleichbar ist die ein
zeitalter quasi geprägt hat wird er
glaube ich in den nächsten jahren ein
guter könig sein bis er dann an einen
seiner söhne william aller voraussicht
nach über geben wird ich glaube wir
werden erleben dass er sozialer empathie
zeigt ja das hat er immer getan er wird
sich etwas tun indem er bestimmte
initiativen besucht menschen besucht
warum sucht so dass er das kann man weiß
zusammenhält das hängt nicht am königin
in london die die diese mächte wollen
nicht mehr einer also wenn es auch nur
staatsrechtlich formal ist einer
früheren kolonialmacht in europa unter
stehen kanadas ein selbstständiger staat
australien selbständig kanada aber
zumindest gut tun wenn die nicht mehr
zum commerce gehör finde ich weil man
dann sehr unabhängig war nimmt das tut
man heute fast nicht also irgendwie
gehören die noch zu großbritannien die
australier auch ist einfach vorbei wie
zeit ist vorbei der kolonialismus ist
vorbei und die wollen sich frei
monarchie dann noch zeitgemäß für
großbritannien im moment ja also solange
es charles gelingt das vereinigte
königreich also england schottland
nordirland wales zusammen zu halten dann
hat eine funktion wenn das nicht gelingt
weil die schotten schon mal gehen
vielleicht an die iren hinterher
ist es schon sehr fragwürdiger größe
dann wird man eine diskussion geben ob
nach ihm nicht das besser zu ende ist er
wird aber um dann nochmal darauf
zurückkommen ich glaube dass er genau
wahrnimmt was in england schief läuft
die konservativen haben dort eine
schreckliche soziale spaltung
herbeigeführt habe eben erzählt davon
dass menschen sich die zähne selbst
ziehen weil sie niemand zum zahnarzt
gehen können dass in england weit
verbreitete geschichte die armut greift
um sich und ich traue list fass als
neuer ministerpräsident ist darin
nicht zu dass sie da wirklich einen
völlig anderen impuls gibt sie ich halte
sie für schwächer als bei johnson und
sie ist nun das amt gekommen weil gegen
ihnen ihren gegenkandidaten zu nach
rassistische bedenken bestanden bei
vielen mitgliedern ihrer partei bitte du
hast lange in england lebt ist es
wirklich so düster in england wie ist
gerade auf gezeigt er hat dieses land
funktioniert im moment einfach nicht da
hat unrecht muss ich sagen und die queen
war das habe ich ja eingangs gesagt war
immer so der eine faktor diese eine
anker der kompass der das alles zusammen
gehalten hat und einmal eine kleine
denksportaufgabe in die runde ich würde
sagen wenn jetzt wohin angekündigt
worden wäre charles macht es nicht und
will ihm hätte sich auf den balkon in
balmoral oder irgendwo anders
hingestellt und gesagt wir haben alle
zusammen entschieden ich mache es jetzt
dann würde was du gesagt hast nämlich
dass das kommen wort auseinanderbricht
nach und nach nicht passieren also wir
leben würde jetzt zusammenhalt da würde
es zusammenhalten denn dann gäbe es
jetzt stichwort zeitenwende ein moment
in dem alle sagen ach vielleicht doch
denn er bringt diesen jugendlichen guten
esprit mit denen es jetzt braucht und
charles dazu viel falsch gemacht ihr
habt doch gesagt er war ein schlechter
vater und sein vater war ein schlechter
vater er war genauso ein schlechter
vater er hat zu viele fehler gemacht die
leute vertrauen ihm nicht mehr ist er
hat das vertrauen der leute verloren
glaubt nichts gehört aber glaubt es
nicht nein das glaube ich gar nicht also
ich glaube nicht dass es jetzt an
william das elster derjenige wäre da das
commonwealth zusammenhalten würde ich
glaube dass charles ein guter könig sein
wird und ich glaube auch zumindest hört
man das auch aus dem umfeld immer wieder
er war ein sehr guter vater er ist ein
guter fahrer musste lernen ein guter
vater zu werden weil der jänner einfach
diese über mutter war und natürlich die
ganzen sympathien auf ihre seite gezogen
hat mit dem tod von der jänner ist er
mit den söhnen viel enger zusammen
gewachsen und ich glaube er ist ein
fantastischer großvater auch das hast du
gesehen thronjubiläum wie die kinder
seine nähe gesucht haben und wir wie der
kleine louis auf seinem schoß saß ich
glaube macht dass er wird es gut machen
er wird auch moderner sein als wir
denken er wird auch viel prunk weg
neonazi jetzt und er hat ja schon
angekündigt zusammen mit william dass
sie auch die königsfamilie an die wollen
ja in schlanken verschlanken also die
wollen ja ganz viele vieles weg lang
mitglieder ist mitglieder aber auch
dieser ganze produkt ich glaube das wird
er nicht machen und er wird ein guter
könig sein als charles ist seit dem die
ehe mit camilla
akzeptiert ist und zwar nicht nur am hof
sondern auch in der bevölkerung weil die
menschen verstanden haben dass camilla
wirklich die liebe seines lebens ist und
eine coole frau ist das sind ja das ist
ja die school dieser macht die
humorvolle die ist das witzig dies
intelligent die fügt sich in die
mechanismen dieses hofes das ist ja
nicht einfach aber seitdem das alles
akzeptiert ist und eine bevölkerung
akzeptiert ist und das verhältnis zu den
söhnen es genau wie sie sagen wenn sich
nach dem tragischen tod von ihrer mutter
so positiv entwickelt hat und er dann
auch noch am hof in diese rolle rein
gewachsen ist zum de facto könig hinter
der königin ist charles ganz bei sich
und ich glaube deswegen also wenn
william auf dem balkon treten würde und
so eine art putsch machen würde ich bin
es jetzt und nicht mein vater ja das
wäre eher ein hinweis darauf sein ding
nicht gelohnt hätte er natürlich tun
können aber ich glaube das ist in der
tradition der britischen krone nicht
sinnvoll auch nicht so gedacht charles
ist der de facto monarchin ganz ehrlich
gesagt ich meine elisabeth über die wir
hier heute abend reden waren nicht
glücklich darüber dass sie so früh in
verantwortung haben und das will dann
muss man
das muss weil sie ihrem enkel jetzt
wirklich nicht wünschen ist es völlig in
ordnung wenn william und kate noch ein
paar jahre so ein bisschen den
schlagschatten eines königs charles
haben und die genießen können aber
unvergessen ist natürlich bei den briten
das charles darwin nur benutzt hat um in
kinder zu gebären und sie hinterher
hatten allein deswegen sollte er doch
nicht könig werden das ist jetzt so wie
es gekommen ist ich glaube dass es
inzwischen erkannt und und auch
weitgehend verarbeitet aber unvergessen
ich glaube da hab ich stimme das ist so
das einladen
wie stehen wir alle haben sie darauf zu
er wird ein anderer könig sein dann wird
im prinzip ein guter könig sein aber für
mich ist die viel spannendere frage was
passiert denn jetzt eigentlich mit
großbritannien also im vereinigten
königreich die kolonien können wir
vergessen die zeit ist vorbei ob die nun
austreten oder nicht da fällt kein sack
reis um von ja das wollen wir selber
entscheiden dann fallen die würfel auch
nicht in london sondern in ottawa oder
sonstwo aber was passiert mit dem braig
cit dies ist großbritannien ist ohne
diese frau über die wir heute abend
reden ein ein deutlich schwächeres land
und in zwei jahren drei jahren haben das
möglicherweise mit einer welt zu tun die
beherrscht wird von donald trump
wiedergewählt wladimir putin und herrn
ski in peking ja da hat schon die eu
jede menge im sich dagegen einigermaßen
zu behaupten aber dann das kleine
großbritannien am rand das von trump
auch noch weg gestoßen wird
kann nichts dagegen tun das hätte jemand
das darf sie auch nicht da hätte jemand
aus dem königshaus mal ein hinweis geben
müssen das ist gut für großbritannien
wert gewesen wäre in der europäischen
union zu bleiben es hat keiner von denen
getan deshalb glaube ich auch dass die
denex austritt wollten den niederlanden
gehen weil sie geglaubt haben stop mal
weil sie geglaubt haben das macht die
monarchie nur stärker ein als
großbritannien für sich
hat er mal mit jemandem gerätehaus auf
der you mit gelben sternen
also was wird da wachs da sagt gerade
sagt das ganz interessante punkt sie hat
ja ihre queen's speech gegeben wirklich
eine europafahne gekleidet auf laura
gelbe punkte
da hat die ganze welt gesagt das ist ein
zeichen auf der anderen seite ohne
jorges ich würde da knallhart
widersprechen wenn die queen sich in der
praxis frage öffentlich positioniert
hätte hätte sie die hälfte sagt verloren
1 1 1 jemand anders aus dem königshaus
hätte eine rede halten nämlich wurde
letztes jahr will damit regens er getan
die haben schon die haben sie schon
dafür ausgesprochen
also gegen den text meine ich jetzt sie
haben schon kleine zeichen die
königsfamilie spricht ja die halten sich
und politik angehen dass darf das nicht
spannende frage ist doch was wird jetzt
raus und ich glaube dass liszt rus
versucht noch den alten fahrt zu folgen
sie ist war früher gegen beck sieht
jetzt ist sie heftige befürworterin die
frau hat sowieso keinen langen bestand
glaube ich die wird unter den problemen
england hat sich ihre rezeption fährt
unter den problemen zusammenbrechen weil
die politik die die konservativen haben
dem nicht angemessen ist und dann muss
man gucken wie er hinterher kommt aber
dieses kleine großbritannien
widerständen wir stellen uns mal die
welt vor mit diesen drei jahren hat die
dann miteinander sich die welt auf teil
der raum damit
gute nach bitte also mit diesem drove
nahrung lesen grusel szenario ob die
queen so verehrte gegen die an einer na
ja nein ich bin ich meine nur da ist man
in europa immer noch besser aufgehoben
auch wenn die eu-troika sich relativ
ausgewechselt und natürlich darf und
darauf reagieren bestritten ja das war
ich meine es war eine der wirklich
wesentlichen entscheidung wo ein
ausgereifter nationalstaat eine eine
eine reife demokratie sich sehenden
auges und beide füße geschossen hat es
eigentlich seine absurde entscheidung
wie schneidet man wenn seine eigene
wirtschaft vom größten markt ab den man
hat selbst wenn man europa nicht liebt
selbst wenn man die eu für kompliziert
und intransparent hält ich sehe das
anders ich kenne den laden ich weiß dass
das anders ist aber die briten haben es
so gesehen selbst dann schneide ich mich
doch nicht von meinem größten geraten da
sind wir uns alle einig der praxis war
falsch nur und ich glaube das darf man
jetzt auch nicht dass jetzt auch nicht
überhöhen die rolle der krone in der
britischen verfassung tram putin die
queen hätte daran nicht so wahnsinnig
viel eine ablösung gar nicht gemeldet
dass die queen da was hätte gegen machen
und ich gucke jetzt nach vorne und sehe
dieses kleine großbritannien außerhalb
der eu für sich alleine mit einem
relativ schwachen könig gemessen an ihr
und einer noch viel schwächeren
premierministerin und da müsste die
debatte endlich wieder losgehen wo
gehören die hin
wird es anders machen als seine mutter
aber ich glaube nicht dass er schwach
ist
glaub ich geheilt eine astras
einzusetzen denn es ist ja wirklich
ironie des schicksals dass sie wirklich
48 stunden später nein niemand glaubt
freiwillig früher oder später das ist
irgendwie h das macht
charakteristisch für elisabeth dass sie
noch zwei tage vor ihrem tod ihre
pflicht als repräsentanten als trägerin
der krone nachkommt im stehen und im
stehen und die nächste premierministerin
des vereinigten königreichs majesty's
government einsehen wenn also das ist
doch ein punkt ist und wegen wir alle
sagen das war ja ihre erste frage was
bedeutet diese frau was hat sie bedeutet
und das ist dieser anker der stabilität
pflichtbewusstsein anstand
fleiß gewisse zurückgenommenheit also
keine exaltiert hat sie hat eben diesen
diesen gesagt noch mal diesen begriff
auch wenn er ein bisschen überladen sein
mag aber dieser anker dieser anker auf
den vielen menschen schauen konnten und
sagen mensch da ist was was ist stabil
das sind tugenden die sind die mücken
aus einer vergangenen zeit stammen aber
sie haben immer noch ein wert und 48
stunden vor ihrem tod nimmt sie noch den
amtseid der neue nicht
dass wir vor der anderen zeigen ich
glaube nach den beiden siegen danach
einfach noch besser halten
das war
überhaupt legitim wenn sie daran ein
interesse hatte an dieser macht übergab
dann war es nicht liest rastan wollte
sie bei uns johnson gehen sehen das war
ein borris sonst es war pflichtgefühl
geritten sind derartig geladen gewesen
auch wisconsin und ich glaube das
königshaus auch der hat england so
wahnsinnig geschah aber das ist ja über
den tonen gesprochen und einer hat heute
auch kommentiert ein redakteur dass eine
der größten der greatest -generation
jetzt auch noch gegangen ist sind diese
werte nicht mehr en vogue sind sie
aufsteht queen elizabeth ist eigentlich
die zweite für werte die heute gar nicht
mehr so gelebt werden das ist eine
interessante frage des jahrgang 1926 das
heißt wir bei kriegsende war sie 19 und
sie hat ja im krieg auch ihre rolle
gespielt als ermutigung erst als sie als
kind unterwegs war mit mit
radiosendungen für auf dem bbc
kinderkanal sie war dann
lastwagenfahrerin in der britischen
armee sie hat also das getan was man von
allen england erwartet im zweiten
weltkrieg und heute die frage ist das
vorbei ja für uns wir haben jetzt 70
jahre 80 jahre frieden und uns erscheint
diese tugenden
ein bisschen aus der zeit gefallen aber
wenn sie junge leute in der ukraine
heute fragen dann sind das genau die
tugenden die da gerade gelebt werden
tapferkeit einstehen fürs vaterland
pflicht gewicht gefühl ich habe in
meinem wahlkreis in bonn eine eine eine
frau die ist zu uns geflogen wird eine
junge tochter die szene der sensoren des
17 der sohn ist nicht geblieben ist
zurückgegangen aber gravierend und
überhöhen dass sie ein bisschen auch
wenn sie die ukraine erwähnen über höhen
wie die königin nicht in ihrer
signifikanz auch wie oft haben wir jeden
tag an die kündigung gedacht nicht so
oft also ich habe das gefühl sie wird
hier stilisiert als jemand der uns alles
wie so eine päpstin geleitet hat durch
den alltag das war sehen wer das war's
ich aber sie waren fixstern und ja gute
gründe waren ja nur für großbritannien
und das kann man wird sondern für uns
auch du wusstest sie ist und dass sie da
ist hatte eine beruhigende wirkung nicht
nur in london und in england sondern
auch in ganz europa eine ganz
wesentliche figur und ich glaube dass so
werte über die wir eben geredet haben
die entstehen ja nicht aus sich selbst
heraus sondern da braucht es eine
persönlichkeit die die tragen kann und
das war eben durch ihr leben die war
eine solche persönlichkeit die das alles
dann auch vertrauenswürdig und
überzeugend gegeben hat und solche
persönlichkeiten gibt es nicht so häufig
und so hat sie natürlich sagen es kommt
natürlich ein bisschen aus ihrer jugend
nicht ihre halter wurde könig weil sein
bruder abdankte wegen der affäre mit der
amerikanerin und die heiraten wollte das
war keine affäre so viel muss man schon
selbst eine liebesgeschichte mit einer
amerikanerin das war damals unmöglich
ihr vater wurde plötzlich könig der
wollte das gar nicht der stotterte der
war ganz ungeeignet aber sie empfand
glaube ich das verhalten ihres onkels
als eben pflichtwidrig ja wobei wollte 1
gegen da sage ich gern mal das als sie
dann sind ja diese geschichte mit der
amerikanerin dies sozusagen nicht
angemessen gewesen sei für das
königshaus halte ich für eine
vorgeschobene begründung für die
abdankung die beiden der könig und sein
amerikanischer geliebte waren die nazis
zugetan und er war ja auch nach der
abdankung
bei hitler auf dem berghof er hat ihnen
da besucht in deutsch
sagen die mussten das wird in england
sachen drüber diskutiert mussten die usa
debattieren tatsächlich
und die waren nicht mehr religiös und
das war ein problem der ist nicht mehr
in die kirche gegangen die queen ist
jeden sonntag in die kirche ganz vorne
tiefreligiöse person als oberhaupt der
kirche sie hat dieses amt wird 1 1 geht
und man ja auch das oberhaupt der
anglikanischen kirche ja ja indem sie
doch wie eine päpstin für die partie
übrigens auf jedem auf jeder münze steht
defender of the face verteilt die krise
ist glaube diese neigung des königshaus
damals in 30er jahren zu den nazis ist
eine sache über die die langsam selber
geredet haben das ist in großbritannien
kein geheimnis mehr wird nicht nur
darüber getuschelt das letzte unbekannte
fällt ist noch warum es rudolf es der
stellvertreter hitlers dorthin geflogen
um frieden zu machen die fakten sind
nach wie vor gesperrt ich weiß ob die
jemals zu gesicht kriegen ist jedenfalls
spannend man kann nur vermuten dass der
mann auf bestehende verbindungen ins
königshaus
zurückgreifen wollte und versuchen
wollte damit leuten zu reden das wissen
wir ja auch also beim fallschirm
abgesprungen war hat an abstimmten namen
gefragt und georgia hat ihn abkassiert
dann hat das nicht zugelassen dass die
gespräche stattfinden das ist die letzte
unbekannte die kleine unbekannte heiter
können dass dieses düstere kapitel genug
aufgearbeitet im prinzip geben sie ja zu
dass etwa die achter nazi geneigt war es
auch nicht zu verschweigen weil der war
ja in auf dem berghof beutler ist
persönlich empfangen worden hat mit dem
gespräche geführt und wolle simpson war
auch eine frau mit nazi neigungen gab es
übrigens viele aber auch der chef von
ford damals henry ford war nazi geneigt
ja das ist richtig aber das waren die
30er jahre ist sie würde jetzt zu weit
wäre ja dass ich bin historiker ich habe
über die genau die zeit meiner
abschlussarbeit das würde zu weit führen
jetzt dahin zu gehen aber ich glaube
kommen wir zurück zu elisabeth für sie
war glaube ich das verhalten von edward
und nicht so sehr seine politischen
überzeugungen sondern sein privates
verhalten ausschlaggebend dafür dass sie
was anderes leben wollte und ihrem volk
was anderes geben wollte und ich glaube
das hat sie auf einer art und weise
getan vor der wir uns heute nur
verneigen können haben wir dürfen nicht
vergessen welche rolle prinz philip
dabei gespielt hat der das königshaus
gewaltig modernisiert indem er
beispielsweise dafür gesorgt hat dass
ihre krönung im fernsehen übertragen
wurde es war das erste mal da hat man
die live turnieren kommt bei 177
menschen zugeschaut immer noch eine
absoluten chaos wahre zahl wenn man sich
das vorstellt aber ich habe jetzt so
viel über sie als frau gesprochen als
mensch und findet ihr nicht dass man so
gewiss diese qualitäten auch in kate
sehen kann ich habe in cambridge
studiert ich war vier jahre und ich
haben kate sieht ja auch die herzogin
von cambridge eben zweimal begegnet im
zuge dessen einmal war sie da in meinem
ersten jahr aber im letzten jahr und
beide male habe ich gedacht mensch das
ist so ein mensch der diese ganzen
tugenden diese dieses absolute sich
hingeben dem staat und der aufgabe so
verkörpert und deswegen muss ich noch
mal zurückkommen auf meine eingangs
these dass wenn william jetzt könig
würde wäre sie königin und das ist
vielleicht genau das zeichen wo es jetzt
nach schreit ich nehme das anders war
für mich sind das beides blasse figuren
und insofern bin ich froh dass charles
jetzt könig geworden ist weil er ist
eine persönlichkeit mit ecken und kanten
über den weiß ich persönlich auch
einiges und ich bin gespannt darauf was
er daraus macht in wirklich gespannt
drauf ich auch und ich glaube die andere
frage ist eine sehr theoretische nicht
interessant wenn man sie selbst erlebt
hat hat man natürlich ein anderes bild
ich habe kate nicht selbst erlebt also
viktor wachs hat dann besseren eindruck
aber ich glaube noch mal die kontinuität
linie der krone führt jetzt zu charles
und es wäre charles eigene entscheidung
gewesen zu sagen ich trete aus der linie
aus und lasse beleben den vortritt aber
daher eben schon so lange faktisch die
geschäfte führt der was die familie ja
selber nennt die firma er ist schon
lange der ceo der firma ja nicht
derjenige der draußen steht das ist das
war seine mutter aber jetzt wird er auch
derjenige draußen steht es wäre für ihn
ich glaube auch also dass wir ganz schön
hart der ganz schön hart jetzt zu sagen
lieber prinz charles
nach jahrzehnten der aufopferung in der
zweiten reihe und jetzt nicht und sie
sagen ich glaube auch gar nicht dass die
so denken also für die ist das
selbstverständlich für die familie also
es ist jetzt ist charles dran er ist der
geborene thronfolger und er ist 73 jahre
alt geworden und hat jetzt so lange
darauf hingearbeitet
und wenn er nicht mehr lebt dann kommt
william plane ich glaube gar nicht dass
prinz william und auch nicht kate den
wunsch haben jetzt könige königinnen zu
werden und ich finde übrigens dass kate
ist fantastisch macht also einen
fantastischen job das ist eigentlich sie
ist die perfekte die perfekte frau des
künftigen königs von england und die
engländer lieben kate
du warst ja auch vorbild 20 jahre bund
sondern sein
buntes tape fehlt ja auch auf das
titelblatt muss man sagen hey das
fantastisch und also ich finde dass sie
auch hohl sind verkauft auch absolut
ruhig und doch oder ja aber für jeden
fall als ich sie ist auch beliebter als
megan also auch was das ist kein muss
ich nein aber am anfang ich muss zugeben
ich war großer fan von megan ich habe
natürlich zugeguckt also die serie bei
netflix in der serie anwalt angestellte
spielte und ich war begeistert am anfang
als harry alles bekannt wurde dass harry
und megan dayton und dass er sie heilig
war großer fan und sie hat es komplett
versaut muss man wirklich sagen und dorf
schauspieler nie für ihre rollen nehmen
ja sie hat es komplett versaut und sie
hat es ja geschafft wirklich ihre eigene
familie sie sie schimpft ja nur bei der
eigenen familie und schimpft jetzt auch
über das königshaus und sie hat einfach
nicht verstanden da kommt eine
amerikanerin und sie dachte sie kommt
jetzt dahin weil sie eine kleine rolle
hat oder dann im laufe der jahre ein
bisschen größere rolle hatte und sie
dachte sie kommt jetzt nach england und
sie wird die neue casey wird die nummer
eins aber sie werden nie die nummer eins
geworden weil eben harry gar nicht der
thronfolger einem halben jahr sitzt die
bei opa und monetarisiert das was sie
heute an diesem tag wo wir hierzu der
oper ja auch schon genau wird wieder
hingehen und sich eine halbe millionen
dafür auszahlen lassen und dafür
erzählen was da heute passiert ist also
kann es heute eigentlich ist also man
muss ja sagen die sind ja dann
weggegangen es weiß ja jeder inzwischen
also beiden haben wir england verlassen
harry ist mitgegangen aus liebe nach
amerika ich glaube er ist zutiefst
unglücklich und es ist überhaupt nicht
sein leben was er da jetzt leben aber
sie genießt es natürlich und sie nutzt
ja nach wie vor alle vorteile dieser ehe
als sie sagt zwar sie willig zum
königshaus gehören und sie will auch
nicht die vorteile nutzen und die
bodyguards und die fahrer und das geld
und das ansehen aber kein mensch würde
nach meggen kein hahn wird nachher gehen
wenn sie nicht mit prinz harry
verheiratet wäre er geht mit ihr nach
amerika ist todunglücklich
ich will das so gibt es doch sicher dass
es ist von hatte sein ganzes leben
hinter sich gelassen hat das königshaus
wie er groß geworden ist seine freunde
als im monat diese er auch keinen
bestand die wird auch nicht ewig auch
aber sie will ja sie hat ja höhere ziele
also sie will ja präsidentin wir geben
in einem ganz kurzen unterbrechung und
sprechen dann gleich wieder über die ja
die mitglieder ist königshaus aber vor
allem über die verstorbene queen
[Musik]
die amerikaner haben nach diesem video
gesagt es reicht wir haben genug
bild
am strand wird nicht gekickt da wird
gezaubert
akrobatische haben sie fußball noch
nicht
alle tore highlights alle großen
turniere
beachsoccer tag bei dem
[Musik]
bild
die queen ist heute verstorben alter von
96 jahren und wir sprechen heute über
ihr vermächtnis aber vorher wollen wir
uns einmal die fünf eindrucksvolles
moment in ihrem leben anschauen
am 21 april 1947 absolviert die queen
damals noch prinzessin ihren ersten
großen internationalen auftritt bei
einem staatsbesuch in südafrika es ist
ihr 21
geburtstag dort hält sie eine
rundfunkansprache in der sie sich zum
dienst am gemeinwohl verpflichtet die
rede ist wegweisend für ihre zeit als
königin
ein jahr nach dem plötzlichen tod ihres
vaters wird elisabeth zur königin
gekrönt das jahrhundertereignis in der
westminster abbey sehen 300 millionen
zuschauer live im fernsehen die
zweistündige prozession durch london
wird zu einem spektakel mai 1970 erstes
bad in der menge sydney während eines
staatsbesuches in australien entscheidet
der palast die monarchien muss mehr
volksnähe zeigen daraufhin läuft sie
durch die begeisterten menschenmenge
1992 das horrorjahr charts und trainer
trennen sich andrew und fergie aus
schloss windsor brennt fast ab zehn
jahre später feiert die queen das
goldenen thronjubiläum es ist der 24
sechster 2002 eine million menschen auf
den straßen londons abends großes
popkonzert vor dem buckingham-palast
22 juli 2013 london die geburt von
prince george macht die queen zur
urgroßmutter
erstmals in der geschichte der
britischen monarchie leben vier
monarchen zur selben zeit der zehnte
april 2021 ist ein schwarzer tag für die
queen nach mehr als 70 glücklichen
ehejahren stirbt der mann der queen
während der trauerfeier wirkt die queen
gedankenverloren und einsam die bilder
bewegen die welt juni
2022 die queen feiert 70 jähriges
thronjubiläum
vier tage lang dauern die
feierlichkeiten
zehntausende menschen ehren die
monarchie
graf lambsdorff so verbindet man die
queen die welt trauert um die queen
welchen moment teilen sie am meisten
wenn sie eine queen denken an welchen
moment ihres lebens also eigentlich ist
es der moment in dem sie vom tod ihres
vaters erfahren hat sie war ganz jungen
der tod war nicht abzusehen sie war zwar
kurz nach dem zweiten weltkrieg
großbritannien berappelte sich wie der
rest europas auch nach diesem
schrecklichen jahren dass der zerstörung
und sie musste dann plötzlich ihr
eigentlich ja vorgesehen ist
unbeschwertes leben als junge frau dem
geliebten ehemann auf geben sich ganz
aufgeben aber sie muss das umwandeln in
ein leben der pflichterfüllung des
protokolls der enge auch und das war
glaube ich diese diese bilder wieder in
kenia unterwegs sind dieser kontrast
zwischen dieser freiheit als junges paar
unterwegs im commonwealth irgendwo und
dann diese hoch protokollarischen
zeremoniellen krönungs festivitäten das
fand ich also sozusagen ganz am anfang
eigentlich das beeindruckt die zweite
szene ist natürlich glaube einer die
niemand vergessen kann das war als sie
endlich nach langer zeit langem zögern
ein blumenmeer entlang schritt dass die
menschen für deren haus geht ich habe
noch in erinnerung er liegt uns
deutschen glaube ich ein stück noch mehr
ist wenn auch nicht so emotional mehr
heute und bei vielen die es gar nicht
wahrgenommen haben 65 erster
staatsbesuch in deutschland 20 jahre
nach kriegsende da war davon sozusagen
auf britischer seite gar keine rede mehr
also das war eine große
versöhnungs reise und die deutschen
männer total hin und weg von dieser
könige und ja und das war schon ein
zeichen der sehr deutlich ist der
rückkehr deutschlands in sachen h die
zivilisierte westliche welt
meine zwei bilder wenn ich dann die
kündigung denke die glaube ich immer
bleiben ist einmal letztes jahr im april
hatte man gestorben ist und sie allein
in dieser kirchen bank sitzt bei der
beerdigung und versunken also wirklich
in sich zusammengesunken und die drei
sind eher gelassen ihr gekommen
das hat mich erschüttert dieses bild zu
sehen und das war nicht der anfang vom
ende von queen elizabeth alles hat sie
nie verwunden dass ihr mann gestorben
ist klar 75 gemeinsame jahre also dieses
bild werde ich nicht vergessen und dann
beim thronjubiläum jetzt im juni als sie
am letzten abend am sonntagabend noch
mal raus kam auf dem balkon niemand hat
damit gerechnet dass sie kämen nicht sie
schaffte es nicht es ist zu anstrengend
und dann kommt diese kleine person mit
ihrem stock in diesem knallgrünen kleid
mit diesem gut und sie hatte diesen
schwarzen ja diese haarnadel diese hut
nadel im hud es war ja auch noch mal ein
zeichen an prinz philip an ihre große
liebe und da steht sie und das publikum
ist ausgeflippt diese hunderttausende
menschen die da am palast stand sind
ausgeflippt freude weil sie da war und
das hat mich auch zu viel häufiger im
jahr viel verzeihen müssen weil als er
etwas jünger war in das königshaus zu
eng war auch ihre amtsführung zu eng
wann ist er häufig nachts verschwunden
und hat mit kumpels angenommen er wäre
kann für seine scherze die nicht immer
gut es ging sehr sehr viele gute scherze
vor allem in afrika das wäre heute ein
richtiger schwerer rassistischen fall
was der alles gesagt hat aber der ist
nachts abgehauen und ist mit seinen
freunden trinken gegangen und da gab es
auch frauenbekanntschaften daneben das
wusste sie auch sie so zugetragen worden
sie hat das aber sie wusste wie eng das
für ihn war und sie hat das ausgehalten
nicht so einfach aber prinzipiell auch
im film hat ja gesagt einmal wie grenze
nötig die königin ist also das war seine
antwort wie gross würde ich die königin
ist aber auch wie leidenschaftlich die
königin und trotzdem ich glaube die
hatten auch ein gutes liebesleben die
beiden war es ernst geworden wäre graf
lambsdorff hat trotzdem ja gerade von
einer firma geredet und ich glaube dass
diese großherzigkeit ja die gab es aber
diese kaltherzigkeit die hartherzigkeit
von der wir vorhin gesprochen haben die
gab es auch und weil man es bei dieser
firma verglichen haben kann man ja auch
sagen dass prinz andrew entlassen wurde
einfach so führt sie der andere anderes
königs
firma sage ich ja schon königsfamilie
mitglied prinz andrew ist ja eher das
sollte ja war es eigentlich
lieblingssohn es hieß immer sei ihr
lieblingssong gewesen aber ich muss
sagen da muss ich dir widersprochen
widersprechen auch da war sie durch und
durch die königin die nur an ihr volk
gedacht hat nur in die krone gedacht hat
und nun daran dieses königshaus zu
retten sie hat gesagt sie nimmt ihn raus
aus dieser königsfamilie müssen die
zweite reihe ist kurz einzuordnen warum
musste er raus was da passiert ja gegen
prinz andrew gab es oder gibt es ja nach
wie vor vorwürfe dass er mit sehr jungen
mädchen sich eingelassen hat da ging es
ja um den hättest zugeführt wurde
inspiriert wurden dieser ganze ja dieser
ganze missbrauchs-skandal und gab es ja
auch an klagen und alles also das ist
schon gibt auch fotos la vor genau also
vergessen das ist auch ganz schlimm aber
ich muss sagen da hat sie als königin
hat sie gesagt okay er muss raus aus der
königsfamilien das zweite war auch die
feuerwehr hat schon eine ganze weile
gewartet bis ist aber ja war das mutter
hat sie immer zu ihm gestanden und schon
jetzt zahlt die gleiche abstraktion um
so eine gute entscheidung auch zutreffen
resultat hat es schon gesagt charts und
will niemand mehr beide gesagt sie
werden eben die königsfamilie
verkleinern und wirklich nur noch der
inner circle wird eben teil dieser
familie sein und dazu gehört eben auch
andrew und da haben sie beide gesagt er
gehört nicht mehr als er gehört zur
königsfamilie wird keine repräsentativen
pflichten und aufgaben mehr waren eher
abwehr wird dieser enge werke seien also
wer es genau ist kann ich jetzt nicht
sagen aber tatsache ist dass man
seitens schon des hofes schon vor
einiger zeit entschieden hat die königin
und charles zusammen dass man das
teilweise wirklich völlig aus
der königlichen familie also da war hier
noch ein und da noch ein jugend und da
noch ein und da machen so dass man das
nicht mehr wohl vor drittelende rein gar
nicht zu reden das ja dass alles anders
wird wirklich auf den auf den inneren
kern konzentriert also diejenigen die in
der thronfolge stehen
und ich glaube das ist auch ganz gut es
ist auch in den zeiten viktor wachs hat
gerade gesagt wo es dem land nicht so
gut geht es geht ja großbritannien nicht
so gut ist es ein gutes signal dass die
monarchie hier in der lage ist auch sich
zu bescheiden die die monarchie wir
haben ganz zu anfang von geredet bin
überzeugt ist es ehemalige großreich
wird in dem was davon übrig geblieben
ist noch weiter zerfallen und dann
entwickelt sich diese monarchie in
richtung einer präsidentschaft
das hängt von dem amtsträger ab das kann
man so nicht sagen vermutlich ja weil
das gar nicht anders geht und ich bin
jetzt mal auf charles gespannt weil der
so wie er
sich als persönlichkeit herausgebildet
hat der wird sich jetzt der sozialen
probleme annehmen im land auf der
ökologischen und reden halten die ihn
glaube ich automatisch in widerspruch
zur premierministerin bringen und darauf
bin ich mal gespannt denn das ist sein
ja das ist dass der institutionelle es
ist eine das kann ja sagen was er will
das hat gelegentlich gegeben dass die
unterschiedliche töne angeschlagen
wird noch politisch noch ein bisschen
zweite wand also ein solcher mann der so
gelebt hat und so mit menschen
umgegangen ist ich habe vorhin davon
geredet dass sieben menschen in
großbritannien selbst die zähne ziehen
weil es anders nicht bezahlen können der
kann solche zustände nicht ertragen und
er wird sie beim namen nennen und es
gibt eine sorte hart herziger
konservativer zu der gehört sie die
darüber weg spielen und das wird er
nicht mehr so ohne weiteres gelingen ich
glaube auch nicht dass sie so wahnsinnig
lange im amt bleibt und viele prominente
dass die heute auch kontrolliert haben
nicht ganz so hartherzig wie du übrigens
immer die hartherzigkeit sondern eher
eine große freundin frankreichs hat zum
beispiel manuel makro kontrolliert
worden
checa sohn johannes natürlich die frage
ein graf lambsdorff den europapolitiker
in der runde inwiefern war sie eine
große freundin frankreichs in wie fern
weil sie eine große freunde europas hier
sehen wir auch von den mannheimer kong
den
treatment of france kein theater also
wie viel war sie eine freundin auch von
anderen ländern das ist sehr schwer zu
sagen es ist so schwer zu sagen weil sie
war eine ganz sicher und das meine ich
ganz ernst und ich bin ein bisschen
optimistischer als das war ganz sicher
eine riesige freundin aller nationen dem
commonwealth wir werden also kanada
australien die afrikanischen länder in
asien und sogar dass das war ihr das
sorgerecht am herzen
darüber hinaus hat sie als britisches
staatsoberhaupt natürlich auch sozusagen
die rolle als spitzendiplomaten der
nation ausgefüllt und ist gereist und
hat goodwill produziert also für
großbritannien das war ihre rolle ist so
sieht sich die königliche familie
insgesamt also den sympathien und
goodwill für großbritannien zu erzeugen
das scheint ihr sehr gelungen zu sein
machen hält sie für eine große freunde
in frankreich der staatsbesuch in
deutschland den hat der new york ist
eben erwähnt die besucher die man sie
auch empfangen hat die band da waren
viele sehr harmonischen es gab manche da
hat sie dann also sehr subtil wie es
ihre art ist das nie irgendwie offen
zutage treten lassen aber jeder konnte
sehen als donald trump neben mir her
stapfte dass sie das jetzt nicht so
besonders schön fand herfahren oder vor
ihr
also ich glaube sie hat und das zeigt
auch die das zeigen die reaktionen auf
der ganzen welt sie ist nicht nur als
person sondern auch als
spitzendiplomaten sehr erfolgreich
gewesen und die diese diese
ikone irgendjemand sagte heute mal seit
also wer mit einem bild der queen
irgendwo in afrika in eine kleinstadt
geht da wird die jeder kennen oder in
japan in kyoto da wird sich jeder kennen
oder bei uns in stuttgart jeder würde
vermutlich sogar im kern ist es ist die
berühmteste frau der welt gewesen und
sie hat diesen goodwill für ihr land
erzeugt und das ist ja da haben
natürlich viele länder geglaubt sie sei
eine gute freundin ich glaube ihre wahre
liebe galt wirklich dem großen hof von
einer beobachtung heute berichten ist
sicher viele bilder gezeigt worden die
amerikaner sind haben umgang mit dieser
monarchie immer am ahnungslos ist ein
gewesen neben mir jedenfalls stand joe
biden neben ihr die seine frau noch
daneben und zwar liegen aufgereiht zu
einem offiziellen foto und er trug eine
sonnenbrille eine flieger sonnenbrille
neben der queen ja es ist natürlich eine
todsünde der andere
das darf man ja auch nicht
man läuft nicht davor und um abend auch
nicht einfach nein auf gar keinen fall
also mann machte einen knicks und das
ist ganz klar eine verbeugung alsmann
und knicks als frau aber man umarmt
nicht das ist ganz klar ein jetlag zu ja
auch nicht auf die schulter man schlägt
sie nicht auf die schulter aber man
spricht auch nicht wenn man nicht
gefragt ist irgendwann war sie sind doch
wir sind doch experten wie haben wir uns
jetzt in groben zügen die trauerfeier
und die beisetzung vorzustellen das ist
ja alles komplett geplant da gibt es
jeden tag jetzt genau einen ablauf wie
das passieren wird und
somit seine überführung und aufbahrung
des sarges dass die öffentlichkeit
abschied nemo welt aus passieren prinz
charles die aufbahrung
es wird in westminster abbey passieren
können der wird sie aufgebaut und der
sarg soll auch schon am samstag
überführt werden prinz charles wird
morgen ja nach london kommen mit seiner
frau also das ist ja auch ganz wichtig
camilla auch da weil die königin hat
darauf bestanden dass sie einen titel
bekommt der billigste könige normalen
dass die königs gemahlen wird und das
war auch der künstler ist ja gar nicht
den sack die wir doch war mit dem
hubschrauber nach london geflogen im
saal sitzen das selbst mit einem zug hat
sich die wahl sage ich dann eben oder
die premierministerin sagte ver hin dass
das king charles der dritte morgen in
london ein treffen wird mit seiner frau
und am samstag soll dann der sagt per
zug nach london gebracht wo kriegt ihr
noch mal irgendwann die krone aufgesetzt
in westminster abbey er wird natürlich
aber das kann jetzt dauern also ist ja
jetzt auch nicht die seine entscheidung
sondern das liegt ja jetzt das ist die
entscheidung der regierung aber das hat
ja bei der kündigung hat es ja weit über
ein jahr gedauert bis sie gehören aber
erst jetzt kam neben ihm hinter ihm wird
sie sitzen hinter ihm sie würde hinter
ihm setzen und sie wird eine kleine
krone auftragen eines zepters und
camilla nicht vielleicht sogar die
größte liebesgeschichte im englischen
königshaus weil sie ja wirklich auch
widerstände hatten vielleicht kann ich
würde sagen die königin und prinz philip
das war wirklich eine ganz ganz ganz
besondere liebesgeschichte man sie war
ja noch sie war noch ein kind als sie
sich in den räumen sie war ein kind und
sie hattest du wieso auch sie wollte
diesen mann haben und das britische volk
war ja am anfang gar nicht begeistert
weil er deutsche wurzeln hat und das kam
ja gar nicht gut an im königssaal im
königshaus die waren sich auch nicht so
happy aber vor allem dass das volk wann
ich happy und sie hat ihn durchgesetzt
sie wollte diesen mann heiraten und die
beiden waren ja wirklich 75 jahre ja was
ganz besonderes natürlich charles und
camilla auch eine große liebesgeschichte
leider viel tragischer als jetzt die
königin ihren mann sich außer kommt also
mit diesem ganzen der jänner drama und
was sie vorhin gesagt hat mir jörges ich
glaube er hatte den wunsch wirklich in
diesem moment er wollte sich von camilla
trennen sie war ja auch verheiratet und
damals war es ja wirklich noch so er
musste eine eine tochter aus als adel
aus dem adel heiraten aus der
mittelschicht oder aus dem aus dem müll
aus der mittelschicht in england vor
allem sie musste damals auch noch
jungfrau sei das ist undenkbar wenn man
sowas heute sagt es war aber so und da
jänner die mochten sich schon und ich
glaube er hat sich eingebildet dass er
diese frau lieben kann und er hat sich
eingebildet dass er vielleicht diese ehe
die seine eltern hatten mit ihr
hinbekommt aber es ist halt komplett
muss man sagen leider gescheitert gehört
daran ja nachhinein gezweifelt ob es
ernst gemeint hat ja jetzt war der yen
aber auch nicht die heilige die manche
sie jetzt in stellen wollen
nein und sie hat ja auch sicherlich ich
glaube da sind einfach zwei pole
aufeinander zugelaufen die sich am ende
überhaupt nicht gut getan haben und sie
hat ja auch vieles verbockt er natürlich
auch aber
da haben wir doch mal zum politischen
wie es jetzt weitergeht graf lambsdorff
was können wir denn in deutschland von
könig charles dritten erwarten also
jetzt warten wir mal dass er gekrönt
wird ich glaube dass er für uns das muss
man ganz objektiv und nüchtern sagen
weniger wichtig sein wird dass die neue
premierministerin und was die neue
premier ministerin machen wird ist
majesty's government jetzt
da gibt es einige anzeichen dass man
nervös sein müssen also neue spannungen
zwischen großbritannien der europäischen
union ja liegen genau wegen des
nordirland protokolls und insofern
glaube ich dass wir jetzt die ebenen ein
bisschen trennen müssen wir haben eine
emotionale ebene und die verbindet uns
auf eine ganz merkwürdige aber sie
intensive art und gegen wir heute
nachmittag genauso wir haben die
meldungen wir sehen man die tränen
schossen mit ihrem ja aber eine
emotionale art mit dieser familie die
mit der königin mit dieser mit dieser
unglaublichen person verbunden und wir
müssen dann den nüchtern politischen
alltag bewältigen dafür ist die
regierung zuständig da wird charles
keine große rolle spielen das was
eigentlich für uns die herausforderung
die die frage sein wird ist wird es
charles gelingen als nachfolger seiner
mutter dieselbe integrierende wirkung zu
haben das hat uli jorges gerade gesagt
das vereinigte königreich
zusammenzuhalten einmal die vier
nationen aber daneben auch die
gesellschaft die hier in großbritannien
noch viel stärker geschichte ist als bei
uns in verschiedene klassen und ob er
das schafft er wird er impulse setzen da
bin ich genau ihrer meinung eher wird es
versuchen aber ob ihm das gelingen wird
ist eine offene frage das braucht noch
zwei gar nicht mehr aus deutschland zum
begräbnis reist ich würde stark annehmen
das ist der bundespräsident ist ich weiß
wo ich glaube und der bundeskanzler auch
ja also das halte ich auch für richtig
spannend deshalb kanzlerin merkel
eingeladen wird denn die mochten sich ja
und das ich habe das von recherchiertes
stünde dem palast offen einige weitere
ehrengäste einzuladen da gibt es drei
oder vier plätze und einer davon könnte
an kanzlerin gehen aber vielleicht auch
nicht spannende frage wird charles
versuchen in der klimapolitik die ihm am
herzen liegt eine rolle zu spielen in
dem ein paar wichtige reden hält
beispielsweise an internationalen
klimakonferenzen teilnimmt dort auftritt
als redner und dann zu sagen über den
kopf von patras hinweg ein paar
wahrheiten zu sagen sie ist da nicht
profiliert sich erhalten das sind ganz
spannende frage ich glaube dass er das
will und darauf müssen wir hoffen und
sie sehen ihn ja vielleicht auch mal bei
einem empfang und irgendeiner muss ihm
sagen machen sie es bitte wenn sie da
ein kleiner im sinne dass wir haben die
hoffnung nicht aufgegeben dass
großbritannien in die eu zurückkehrt
sein wunsch an
tanja
ich wünsche ihnen von herzen dass er die
fußstapfen seiner mutter ausfüllt weil
diesen enorm groß und aber ich bin
sicher er schafft es
ich wünsche ihm das gar nicht ich
wünsche ich mir dass seine ganz eigene
spuren legt und gar nicht erst versucht
an seine mutter anzuknüpfen und von
wegen die da in die fußstapfen des soll
sein eigenes ding machen da sind ganz
anderer mensch er hat ganz andere ideen
und die sonne verfolgt man sagt mir dass
alle gespannt wie charles die fußstapfen
ausfüllen wird aber jetzt wollen wir
noch einmal der queen gedenken mit den
schönsten bildern
[Musik]
königin elizabeth ii zweiter hat ihr
ganzes leben in den dienst der krone und
den ihres landes gestellt in guten wie
in schlechten zeiten
sie bestieg den thron des vereinigten
königreichs